[Music]
is
a tv
[Music]
that's a powerful sip yeah careful
hitting that because we have never lost
power here at this studio
that's true it's incredible it really is
it's a blessing
and uh it's also a curse because
everyone else gets to take time off work
but we don't
no snow days hey we are here for you we
did have to reschedule to change my mind
though
mass motor fraud is real wait ban me bro
so uh we have a lot to get today today
listen i just want to let you know we'll
have
uh some a little bit of personal
reflection on a hero of mine and a lot
of people in here rush limbaugh um so
it's not necessarily you know
what is breaking news unfortunately his
passing but uh a little bit of a trip
down memory lane
don't worry we still have plenty of
clips uh from joe biden from the town
hall
they're deep in there misstated facts
regarding vaccines as well as a new gun
control bill
which is really important because
they're using the crime wave to try and
push that on you
uh interesting yeah the crime wave so
they need to institute uh
gun control we have uh gerald a he's
here hi how are you i'm not
how are you yeah you know a little
winded a little
it's because of the sip it's because i
was running around trying to get my knee
brace on
uh quarter black is here i won't tell
you who's in third shirt don't do that
oh
hold on i won't tell you who's in third
chair yet hold it down what's it hold it
down
hold it down lay it down lay it down lay
it down wait what is that thing
you hold it down what's left lay it down
when you're going oh okay
you don't talk about that i want to show
you a third chair yet because there's a
big part of the show today and we
actually have uh some medical advice
today on the show which you're not
supposed to dispense on youtube but it's
actually my doctor
what's up doc with dr choi you've seen
him but first before we get to all of
that
we have to honor our brothers and
sisters of
different shades with black history
month
still arabic i don't know it's my
favorite to appropriate is to appreciate
yeah i saw a black guy doing this once
so that's not true uh hit us with some
facts uh
some facts there corner blocks because
you have to say it so that i don't get
banned that's true
yeah and i'm i appreciate it it's just
like i can't open up a taco stand
yeah so rosa parks you all know her her
brave yes
yes axe and montgomery alabama but
little known fact she actually jumped in
the spotlight with her mixtape
front row front row wow also the name of
a record company
front row records uh powerful lady
respect
she also dangled vanilla ice from a
balcony oh oh missed opportunity ninja
turtle rap too just doesn't pay the
bills
better go flip houses um let him go uh
something else too this is also breaking
you have to know about this before we
get to rush limbaugh and joe biden and
the gun control bill which you need to
know about
is uh elon omar join tik tok
[Music]
the worst
a government for the people by the
people here's something funny about that
uh actually music is haram according to
hadith
i think we have a little haram haram
thing yeah
at the end of the day yeah that looks
like you're it's haram music is haram
and islam so
she's just a really bad muslim perfectly
acceptable banging your brother
yeah and no one tries to and you can't
take that away we can never take away
from her
that she married her biological brother
that's her even snopes has to say
move on move on that's a fact
it is verifiably true elon omar your
representative
stopped her brother stephen let let him
who hasn't cast the first stones i mean
all of us
what offends me most is the dancing in
that video more than anything else well
you know who it hurts most
allah
cry and that's why you have the
snowstorms uh but
again before we move to uh it's still
holland is tears or snow yeah his tears
are snowing
his tears are snow he's a cold god he's
a cold god a merciless god
and a hateful vengeful god but only if
you don't convert
submit or die or pay the tax relief you
have some you have some options
with islam hopefully coming to an
american government
you soon by the way who knows we talk
about nepotism
i mean in her case she could actually be
funneling money to her husband as a
company which could be a violation of
could be campaign finance law so she'll
be violating that at the same time
while committing nepotism because it's
also her brother
husband and brother that is a crazy web
husbands
brothers she says that's redundant okay
show me the hadith that forbids it steve
so uh before we move on actually this is
something many of you requested and uh
token allen was the winner last time
between him and my half-assing lawyer
bill richmond but now we have an
intern troy jr who is also fully asian
and so it's time this week we're going
to be checking in with him for our asian
rosaceae
round two
there you go and uh here we go this is
third chair today tokunawan
tokunawan is here now token now you are
in fact asian uh yeah i'm one quarter of
okinawan you're one quarter okinawan
yeah
my quarter brother when you were a baby
you looked really asian and when you
drank and bill
half asian bill richmond drank who looks
full asian um
you were purple that was the color of
your foot you really colored my foot and
my foot had stabbed and right yeah
it was disgusting and now we have uh
junior choi here who's dad dr choi
actually uh is the what's up doc my
favorite doctor ever and you are full
asian correct
yep full korean full korean okay okay so
we're going to see
who gets more pink and that's the winner
whoever gets the most asian rosacea and
we're going to have a what's up doc
segment later for those who are in my
club where he'll explain
the asian glow and also serious health
consequences so this isn't safe
all right it's also early you're going
to start with the shot so one
shot of bourbon we measured this one
shot of bourbon for the asians
okay start that off there you go let me
see all the medicine
i feel like a little bit of sugar helps
the medicine go down
good oh yeah okay we'll check back in
with i think i think brodigan's probably
playing along he's like oh they're
drinking i'll drink well he's irish
he's always playing alongside he's not
pink he's just ruddy uh my question to
you too is did
any of you guys out there listen to rush
limbaugh and have you been following
social media since he
this is kind of where we are he passed
and of course you see liberals
celebrating and
listen that doesn't really bother me
that's all par for the course i was i i
made jokes when ted kennedy died the
difference is rush limbaugh never killed
someone
so um
allegedly allegedly she died because of
him
but maybe he didn't do it deliberately
um so
how do you remember rush limbaugh how
did you find out about them i'm curious
i think this is just the comment section
they would be good
yeah good section for everyone just kind
of kind of congregate and talk about how
you
you you found out about this guy who
really changed the face of media
landscape and that's the best thing you
can do
is just comment that'll help here on
youtube and we try and foster a pretty
good community
we don't censor comments we don't edit
them and uh
most of you are pretty nice surprisingly
which is surprising on the youtube
comment section usually it's awful you
don't expect that yeah uh okay we're
gonna move on by the way merch store lot
of cuttershop.com
this shirt is available all right it's a
deep platform this
and uh the change for mine shirts and of
course we'll be taking your chat on mod
club later this show
is live uh monday through thursday every
morning
10 a.m eastern time okay so a lot of
people don't know this about rush
limbaugh um
whether you like him or not when people
say he changed the face of media
landscape
let me kind of start here from from uh
the beginning you know am radio was
considered dead
yeah at that point it was considered old
it was considered out of touch and so
they thought like oh no one uses am
radio anymore and it comes down to bands
and all the technical stuff
everything was moving to fm and rush
limbaugh
took some am stations and uh he was just
a firebrand he had done the kind of
radio that nobody had done before
he had i don't know how many channels he
had he started with 56
and he ended up with more than 600 and
people talk about big numbers on youtube
and stuff like that and
really before us recently nothing
compared to what rush would get 27
million weekly listeners wow on his show
i would say that's a lot
yeah and that's why the left really
hated because he had power
this was a guy who single-handedly
changed the face of modern conservatism
um and um which is he did a lot
okay and that's why we may not remember
but president trump
a man kind of after his own heart did
this i am proud to announce tonight that
you will be receiving our country's
highest
civilian honor the presidential medal of
freedom
he's genuinely surprised that's a really
touching time
[Applause]
and of course i saw when he died nbc
presented it brush limbaugh dies
a man who was a trump awarded
presidential medal of freedom
known for his racist homophobic
misogynist remarks
of course which uh listen the thing is
people would say racist you see this all
over twitter
do you know his when he talked about
snurly he's a black guy
the one guy in a studio he would talk to
a really big black guy
like a guy a guy who shook knight
he was taking his life forever rush had
very very loyal employees
to know him was to love him and i know
he had several marriages look i'm not
here to say that rush was a perfect
person right
he was a flawed person he had a
painkiller addiction now that came from
him actually having pain an injury and
then that spiral out he wasn't going
down looking for heroin
there's a big difference between
advocating for legalizing all drugs and
saying they're inconsequential in rush
limbaugh saying you know what i
developed a problem
and i'm getting some help and people try
and use that against him and then say we
have a mental health epidemic in this
country
rush limbaugh is a perfect symbol for
what the left says
versus what they believe yeah absolutely
and the liberals hated him so much i
don't know if you remember this but
didn't they try to start their own like
i think it was like janine garofalo and
some other people
if i'm remembering correctly it was it
air america yeah
like that and it just failed
specifically franklin had a show that
franken was part of because
they were furious this is something a
lot of people don't know newer
conservatives you know they were really
mad because they thought
why do we only get abc cbsc and every
other thing
uh nbc msnbc and why does he get all of
am radio and they said well there are
plenty of available stations nobody
wanted it he went there
they tried and they failed because the
am radio format
three hours of talking you better be
interesting and you better be right
yeah absolutely it wasn't even close no
it wasn't close am at the time
if you weren't listening for sports you
pretty much broadly weren't listening to
anyone at all
and i even created they tried to create
legislation which you can look this up
the fairness doctrine where they were
saying you had to
offer equal opportunity equal points of
view
on radio but it wouldn't apply to the
main networks yeah because it wouldn't
apply to cnn yeah
it would only apply because here's the
and this was the problem that people had
that i had with the fairness doctrine
back then if you look it up with the fcc
cnn was considered neutral so they
didn't need to have equal time
opportunity
[Laughter]
so it'd just be msnbc would be the one
that's okay equal time
but fox news and rush limbaugh but cnn
abc nbc cbs are going well that's real
journalism they didn't need equal
opportunity for
the new york times podcast if they had
radio they thought that well we need to
even this out because the one
sort of bastion of conservatism the one
place where someone was being effective
was a lone warrior it was rush limbaugh
you need to understand this it's not
only soldiers who get the presidential
medal of freedom
and we've talked about this with jocko
on the air because he works with
businesses now yeah and he said you know
you're working with people you're
dealing with their lives in the military
but
in a lot of ways it's harder dealing
with businesses because you're dealing
with people who are
responsible for everyone's livelihoods
yeah
the medal of freedom is generally given
to someone
who's taken a risk who's faced extreme
adversity and you can't say that
is not the case about rush limbaugh yeah
foreign former vice president joe biden
too right former vice president joe
biden
yeah that's right um so i have a lot
more we'll talk about
rush limbaugh i want to hear your
stories but first actually i know that
listen
we've had power we haven't lost power my
heart goes out to people who don't have
power
um and we want to be able to help you so
actually um we sent thomas finnegan on
the ground
to give you some tips on how to keep
warm and stay safe
thomasville get on the ground
[Music]
okay thomas finnegan are you there can
you hear me sir
stephen how are you i'm fine thanks and
you what are you doing
well stephen in these frigid
temperatures uh and my house being out
of power i thought it would be
uh good to show everybody how to stay
warm in these in these poor conditions
oh that's good show us how
what we're going to do is you have to go
around your house and find items
that you think will will burn and then
oh yeah you simply add the element of
fire
and then you you'll be warm
we'll be able to keep your family making
a fire warm
all through all through the night yeah i
don't know that that's necessarily
but sure and you don't want to use the
tree limbs because they have snow on
them so
they're not going to burn too easy well
i don't think people are going grabbing
tree limbs no
so no okay i'll try one more
yeah you've got to block the wind i
don't think the wind is your primary uh
problem no you see it's starting it just
takes a few tries and
it's not starting at all thomas there we
go okay
you do that a few times make sure you
have okay you know what we'll check back
in once it gets started thomas finnegan
thanks sir
he has some other stuff to show us
hopefully better than the fire um
you know rush he was inducted into the
national radio hall of fame that was a
big one because it was the top rated
show broadcast out of abc like i said 27
million listeners
um and rush actually a lot of people
don't remember this
he single-handedly this is sorry uh
overlay from the los angeles times
smooth manny because we have drunken
asians here yeah that's true they can't
do overlays and drink
hold on let me check let me tell you
guys let's see that one we got look
token
i'm going to kick his arms powerful yeah
let me see minnie choy
i mean i don't think i see it that much
right now no the lighting is a little
bit more harsh on you but you're still
just
yellow yeah it's very yellow yellow
average asian i mean yellow what do you
what do you prefer uh
yellow okay yellow well it's got to be
i want to make sure we're making him
comfortable yeah we're making him
comfortable
okanawan's already soused yeah um he
single-handedly got newt gingrich
elected a lot of people don't realize he
was
he was made an honorary republican
because of what he did when the
the republicans took the house for the
first time in a generation this is a guy
who had a lot of power that's why the
left hated him they were afraid of him
this was a guy who affected
political discourse and changed the
direction of the republican party
bringing it back to something
more conservative yeah absolutely and
the only like you said just a minute ago
the
the tagline for his death basically was
the racist homophobe
that's the only thing that they could
throw at him was oh he's a racist oh
he's somebody that we can't beat and so
now we have to try and tear them down
it's the same playbook they've been
using all the way up to donald trump we
can't beat him we don't like what he's
doing he's doing something different
he's taking
our audience he took basically social
media that was what barack obama
basically laid claim to in his
presidency right and he came and took it
and they're like oh crap they just took
our ball how do we beat him right
racist rush limbaugh comes to mind we
call him a racist
uh homophobe they don't have that on
donald trump called sandra
did he call her a horror or a
because she was going before congress
demanding free birth control i think so
and i was like well listen hold on a
second
if you were having sandra fluke said she
couldn't afford it
yeah she's like well what if we can't
afford condoms if you are having
so much unprotected sex with strangers
on college campus
that you can't afford 25 cent rubbers at
a truck stop
and you're demanding our taxpayer
dollars and we can't use the word
then you can't use it yeah just say we
can't have that word
so they just say misogynist and people
would see from oh misogynist and then
they understand the story they go oh
yeah that's pretty
she's having so much sex she just
doesn't want here's one too a lot of
people don't remember this in 2008
this is why i think rush limbaugh really
liked president trump um even though at
the time a lot of people were
apprehensive because they didn't think
donald trump would govern very
conservatively and he was a democrat in
new york for a long time
or at least democrat republican wasn't
consistently conservative
um but they were both agents of chaos
this was in 2008 if you don't remember
this and i know some of you are young
who watch this he actually urged his
listeners
to register as democrats do you remember
this i do yeah and vote for hillary in
the primary
against barack obama and it was dubbed
this campaign
operation chaos here you go the success
or the definition of the success of
operation chaos
is just that is there chaos uh the
original purpose of this
before the texas and ohio primaries was
to make sure that obama got bloodied up
politically he was riding the messianic
trail at the time
the mccain campaign had sworn they were
not going to criticize obama
who better than the clintons to do it
but for that to happen the nomination
process needed to be extended
she needed to stay in our purpose is not
to see that either one of these
people get the nomination it is to see
to it that neither of them get it by
virtue the primaries
that the super delegates have to make
the choice and cause all of it chaos
and this is something too that people
don't remember yeah it was going to be
hillary clinton
it remember it was a coordination for
her yeah and then all the celebrities
said
um woman because the whole sexism thing
wasn't really a big deal at that point
in 2008 they acted like it was settled
and now all of a sudden we became
systemically sexist again so they said
woman who you know rented an apartment
in new york and became a senator like
after two weeks
or junior senator we knew nothing about
he's a black guy they all switched
and supported the black guy that's what
happened and clinton was furious
and so what they wanted to do she was
expecting a coronation
yeah and also she was shaking so yeah
she couldn't catch a break
then rush lim uh rush limbaugh decided
to extend this into the primaries
because hillary clinton had such a
such an ego yeah she was fighting for
that celebrity endorsement to come back
and it really did
bloody up obama going through the
primaries there unfortunately at that
point you know
it was john mccain so barack obama won
that's one for you democrat
it was not very exciting something else
too that people don't remember then i'll
get into kind of how i first heard
ruslan but to be fair i've told you i
didn't really listen to him growing up
because i didn't have access to it
uh we had a pirate am radio from
plattsburgh
and at that time of the day we couldn't
really get rush limbaugh there was an
opposing station that had like dennis
prager and michael medved yeah
but then then i had a friend i found out
on the bus this was the first time i
found another conservative in canada
on the bus the 225 on the way home used
to go down tasro and then churchill
victoria okay
anyone who's from greenfield park south
shore comment below you'll remember that
and uh i remember him talking about rush
limbaugh yeah
and he said i said you know rush
limbaugh i said yeah yeah i said how do
you say i
listened to it online and he was telling
me this was before podcast and you had
to like get a local radio station find a
radio station
that was doing the streaming and i
didn't have a computer with those
capabilities i had a laptop
where the only thing i could do was type
or play this game lemmings in black and
white
oh wow nice so then i would go over to
his place
and listen to rush limbaugh a little bit
and i just said what is this this is
this is incredible this guy can just
he's just saying whatever he wants
and it was never mean it was never
vulgar it was never terse it was
edgy um but that was a big that was a
big part of my development i would say
more so with this show david letterman
john stossel because i used to watch him
after tgi tgif and he'd get on
2020. give me a break even though
environmentalists say the hudson river
is incredibly polluted
i'm willing to do this i mean jump in
rafter my wife and kids yeah that's
right no
first it was step by step but i can't
take i can only take patrick duffy and
small doses
but here's something else too rush
limbaugh um he was cancer before this
term cancel culture was a thing
and i wrote the treatment for the book
changed my mind when i was at fox news
and i pitched it to every major
publisher and they said no
and there wasn't really a term for
cancelled culture but i had a whole
chapter on it yeah
and there wasn't a term for sjw i called
them uh i called them modern leftists i
called them american idiots and modern
leftists american idiots were the people
who went along with it who were sort of
democrats by default and modern leftists
were the sjws and academian celebrities
because i didn't there was no words to
describe it
and rush limbaugh would run into this
there weren't words to describe cancel
culture
but uh this was back in 2003. you
probably know this better than i do he
had a stint in the nfl as a commentator
with the espn yeah
short stint he was a short stint
[Applause]
he i think he would have to duke it out
with dennis miller for sure
and it was for entirely different
reasons just that no one understanded
dennis yeah
well now you're looking at warren sapp
who's looking at that ball like a
widescreen imax photographer like
dedrick ferguson who's there at the end
of a cpap
great field of video back to you kid i
love the cut of your chip
yeah what does that have to do with
football well listen we're talking about
american sports you're talking about
redskins who used to play the cross to
the death for four days at a time so all
of a sudden throwing a football behind a
chalk yard line doesn't seem like it's
all too concerning back to you kid
you're fired well you know that makes
sense when you consider okay okay
cut it so rush was on nfl espn he was a
commentator and he was forced to resign
after i'm have to look at this because i
have to get the name right i know
nothing about football
okay uh he made these comments about the
eagles eagles quarterback correct
and who was it yeah donovan mcnabb he
was on no no don't give us the
commentary and you are red
there you're right oh my god he needs to
stop drinking he's on the cover of
madden he was on the cover
okay so donovan mcnabb these were the
comments that got rush limbaugh
cancelled in 2003 from espn
donovan mcnabb is regressing he's going
backwards and
my i'm sorry to say this i don't think
he's been
that good from the get-go i think what
we've had here
is a little social concern in the nfl i
think the media has been very desirous
that a black quarterback do well
black coaches and black quarterbacks
doing well i think there was a little
hope invested in mcnabb
and he got a lot of credit for the
performance of this team that he really
didn't deserve that
but russia carried this team listen come
on you have all the running positions
come on can we just have can can can the
white guys just have quarterbacks
in golf he should have been a running
back because we're going to bring up the
stats in a minute but he had more
rushing outs than he did passing yards
is that what it was yeah i mean
apparently he was right about donovan
yeah no vehicles they they scored three
touchdowns that game i think he
donovan mcnabb was responsible for zero
of them zero rushing
passing he had like 17 yards passing he
got sacked
he had more russian guards he got sacked
twice exactly his passion
completion was really low it was 14
yards like 16
62 i think yeah well his overall point
was accurate right and so
it's not racist to say that the nfl has
a diversity program in place they do
they have to it's called the rooney rule
they have to
interview black head coaches and for
other coaching positions right because
they want more diversity fine
his point was hey this feels like we're
putting too much pressure on this guy
right that's basically what he was
saying to defend almost donovan like hey
i don't think he was that good from the
start you guys are saying he's the
messiah he comes in and underperforms
yeah and now you're crapping on him
guess what the same thing happens with
vince young
yeah vince young there's a qb iq test
okay the quarterback iq test
and we're not saying iq racism
quarterback
nfl like can you be a good quarter would
be a good nfl quarterback
vince young i what my brother was in
school with vince young he was
unbelievably won the uh the rose bowl
national champions national championship
game ever with the nfl
quarterback iq this is a disaster
waiting to happen
uh more vince young scored less than
statistical random
really so if you just randomly answered
the questions you would do better
if if you had if you had a spider monkey
throwing
darts it would do better that doesn't
surprise me a whole lot but they put a
lot of pressure on him the guy broke
down
he did he had a mental breakdown they
should have had a tip off with vince
young when he bought all of the seats to
a southwest flight
and just yeah and which is iron which is
funny because they don't even have first
class period
so he could have actually charted a
private plane he was like he took a
picture remember he's like
look i ain't got look i got my own plane
and there were two people who he
couldn't get to give up their seats in
the back and then they're like thanks
fans
the other thing too about this clip that
we played like limbaugh goes on to say
like
you you got to give credit to the
defense he wasn't he wasn't trying to
on donovan mcnabb he was saying
right it wasn't the reason they won this
game it was the defense played really
well right
yeah yeah and i don't know why it's it's
bad to say okay we we want
inclusive you know we want the nfl to be
more inclusive and we're putting
pressure on people to perform in these
positions
and you're doing it for the wrong
reasons do it because he's a great
question
he was the first guy a lot of people
don't realize this rush limbaugh was the
first guy to talk about you know wokism
and encourage people to think logic
basically what you know now is you know
facts don't care about your feelings ben
shapiro has said that yeah or often
the change my mind changed my mind that
is that was sort of the seedling for a
lot of this
he didn't go out and do change my minds
and this is a guy by the way who's
largely deaf toward the end of his
career people don't know that
yeah um but he was the first person to
describe
sort of the social justice warrior
culture the culture of censorship
from the left and it scared a lot of
liberals because here's the thing
remember they always used to say that's
a conspiracy right oh you're
why are you being so radical keep in
mind rush limbaugh was around when he
said
they want to take your guns away so this
is just some crazy conspiracy theories
and then they did the assault weapons
ban which made the whole country like
california where
this legal pistol grip illegal oh it's
scary
and by the way gun crime uh uh didn't it
didn't work it didn't work it did not
work under
work and then it was recently certainly
the stupidest spill ever because they
want it back um
and i think it's pretty clear to see
look i don't want to remember him just
from the last portion of his life
yeah but uh in his own words these were
his his this was his last broadcast for
those who missed it
my point in all of this today today's
gratitude my my point in everything
today that i
share with you about this is to say
thanks and
to tell everybody involved
how much i love you from the bottom of
my
sizeable and growing and still beating
heart
because i have i've learned what love
really is
during this even in the
most dire circumstances if you just wait
if you just remain open to things
the good in it will reveal itself
and that has happened to me as well but
i don't believe our darkest days are
ahead of us i never
have like people been asking you you've
always told us to be time to panic
because it's time to it's never time to
panic folks there's never ever going to
be time
to give up on our country it'll never be
time to give up on the united states
it'll never be time to give up on
yourself
and that's now we'll have some some
something else that i want to play and i
want people to remember him when he was
when he was healthy but still
that's the message he espoused for a
long time and people have used that term
happy warrior
i've said that some people sometimes
people say you're just peddling opium no
listen
i think that we're going to face some
dark times here we have some challenges
with with joe biden but i do believe
that we still live in the greatest
country on the
face of the earth that's ever existed
and there are systems and checks and
balances that can correct it and i know
a lot of you have lost faith in our
institutions so have i
especially after this last election but
the solution is not just to say well i'm
not going to vote
yeah the solution is not to say well i'm
just not going it doesn't matter anymore
look
look maybe you feel as though we're in a
tough spot with the election maybe you
feel that we're in a tough spot with joe
biden and them having control of the
house in the senate but look
this show keep in mind in 2009 and you
can go to crowder bits and watch crowder
classics where i was
talking about joe biden being a demented
old circus monkey back then
yes he's getting older just so you know
no one was paying me then
and i pay me now people who's paying you
go back to 2009 where i had uh jason
priestley sideburns and a blue bed sheet
i wasn't taking big koch brother money
or fracking wasn't a thing i didn't get
fracking money it was three hundred
thread count
but i haven't even a good one i almost
slept on that
so it is um there but
people often use this sort of this this
negativity this pessimism
as an excuse to absolve yourself of what
you can do you don't think that rush
limbaugh went through some years where
listen
he was there for the whole clinton
administration he was there for the
whole barack obama administration
he was there for the attacks on donald
trump right he was there the whole time
and he didn't just say well it's time to
give up
listen this show this is proof positive
sure
maybe there are some issues where i
think we need to strengthen for example
election integrity that's what i'll say
we need to definitely make sure that
elections are secure we don't have mass
mail and voting i think there's a way
down the line if we play it right that
we can make some corrections but
something like this show right now
this is now the number one conservative
show on on any online platform
any online platform and most news
platforms there's no way this could have
happened in 2009
yeah exactly there was there was no one
do you understand that's why the young
turks used to go after me because they
had a million subscribers
and i had 40. and there was nothing that
we could do you guys
have made this what it is you guys have
created this new movement and if you
keep doing that there will be more
programs like this
look think just this show the hodge
twins weren't conservative
dave landau wasn't brian callan hadn't
come out of the closet there are so many
people who've now decided that it's okay
for them to take part in this fight
look at gina carrano she's being bold
now yeah she was forced to but you know
what she kind of knew she kind of knew
what was coming and she made that
decision
people in positions of power and
influence are becoming
bolder because of we we all owe it to
rush limbaugh initially
and that's allowed us to create this to
make you bolder to make you understand
that you're not alone
that is very powerful there is good
coming on the pike i don't say that
falsely
i try and shoot you straight and tell
you when things look grim this is not
the end of the line and
if nothing else believe that and act on
that
to honor probably the most influential
and greatest conservative of our time
rush limbaugh yeah absolutely and i
think looking back on kind of the 90s
with
bill clinton i don't know one of my
early coaches earlier
exactly one of my earliest memories was
hearing him you know and start his
program by day 362
of america held hostage right you know
like he would always start and i was
just like what the hell is that all
about you know like i would jump in and
listen to the show and kind of learn a
little bit about him but
he he was facing down really dark days
with bill clinton like a sleazeball
governor is now coming to the white
house this sexist
guy is going to come in and do all these
terrible things and he pushed back
you know he didn't you can argue that
under clinton
the budget was balanced because of rush
limbaugh because they called it the rush
limbaugh caucus you had newt gingrich
come in they got control of the house
and they started controlling the purse
rings wasn't ideal but that's why a lot
of people look back and think that bill
clinton was more of a moderate it's
because he didn't have a choice he was
forced
and at that point conservatives
republicans were beholden to people like
limbaugh yeah because they knew that's
the megaphone going out to our audience
and we better hold ourselves accountable
to them so politicians are only
accountable to you
through people like rush limbaugh and
you know god willing i don't put myself
in that bracket now
ourselves right now yeah it's just a
bunch of us trying to fill that gap
meaning multi but no one will ever be
rush limbaugh but
a few of us can rise up and then help
keep conservatives accountable
for you dan crenshaw has some splatting
to do hasn't been back on the show a
little bit pissed off of some of the
stuff that he's done
you saw me go in a little bit with ted
cruz i still like that guy but there are
a lot of republicans who are dead to me
and guess what
they fear us speaking out against them
because they fear you and that's the
same reason that the left
feared rush limbaugh they knew that the
guy had impact for crying out loud
feminazi is a term because of rush
limbaugh he invented it did he really
yeah i didn't know that
yeah called sandra fluke
i remember classic but here in uh in
russia did you do you remember when you
first heard rush limbaugh
uh drunken token by the way hey troy
junior you're getting a little pink
yeah you are coming in all right there
it is there we go he's also feeling
really getting a little i come to win he
is not going to beat me now how do you
guys feel it at all do you feel do you
feel drunk i felt it before the show
when i when i i pulled my beer like a
jackass you cheated no no no no i didn't
cheat i poured my beer too
fast so i had a little bit left in the
bottle and i drank that and i was like
oh that's cheap oh no yeah
i'm done that's cheating like your
people do with the economy the camera
does not do that justice by the way
you like devaluing the currency do you
all right what's your story about rush
limbaugh let's go
i i you you know what for for me it
really i
i heard mostly about rush limbaugh um
i'm like the daily show with jon stewart
and so your your tweet about like
the left being afraid of him it really
it rang true for me because that's
that's all they would
do you know when it came to rush like
they would always try and highlight
of this controversial thing he said oh
he's a racist he's you know he's he's
a terrible human being yeah and so that
that's kind of how i
saw him yeah you didn't like in my
formative years yeah and it wasn't until
later
where i heard him more like in context
and i was like oh this guy's speaking
crazy well i want to
you know i want to tell this and the
thing is i don't know how to tell
without it sounding self-aggrandizing
because i didn't believe it at the time
but that man right there andrew
breitbart
um when he saw that i had been fact
checked at cpac where they said that i
yelled the n-word and i didn't
i was i dressed as thomas said the word
knickers
with k's with k's and there's even a
joke where we had a black producer where
we stopped the record and he looked and
said no i can say knickers because i
wear
knickers that was the joke that's the
joke but they cut it and i got called in
the fox news office and then the next
year they said that i made a joke
they actually judged where it was a joke
about ashley judd saying that purchasing
an apple
phone is akin to raping the environment
but i remember andrew breitbart talking
with me and he said
you know you when i see that now this
has happened two years in a row
it's you know you're in good company
because they're attacking you in a way
that they're not attacking the
politicians you're speaking it's
they attack people like rush limbaugh
and yourself and that's because they're
afraid of rush limbaugh we know that but
for some reason they're afraid of you so
you need to be aware of that and
do your due diligence and wait for the
time to storm the castle
but you have a target on you and i've
seen it that not everyone has
let's go have a drink or four
and i remember talking about that not
you know really moved me
yeah um yeah you have something to say
here yeah i mean you know there was
another
part of that story like you not only did
you have a target on your back but just
like i'm sure rush limbaugh experienced
earlier in his career trying to find
that niche like i'm not sure that rush
went to am radio day one
right and and tried to make it work
there i think there was probably other
stuff somebody confess he went there
because he was the only thing he did
nobody else would like
i'm gonna do my own thing right and that
was me remember
yeah michigan i said as long as you let
me keep the rights and then it got
syndicated
and then i said what is what am i doing
this stupid radio clock let me go online
but you remember that
absolutely in the morning in ann arbor
michigan there were so many so many of
those moments and the reason i tell the
story is not just to
help people see a little bit more about
the behind the scenes for you it's to
say
that could be you right rush limbaugh
could very easily have not been the rush
limbaugh that we know today if he had
not taken a risk if he had not gone out
in his community and it doesn't take
going and starting a channel and going
oh i've got to have a hundred thousand
followers tomorrow
it can take five minutes of you saying
hey like here's a conservative principle
that i believe in this conversation and
two or three other employees may go gosh
i'm glad there's another conservative
here maybe somebody i can talk to now
you know what else i will say rush
limbaugh was flawed
but yeah you can go back to 2009 since i
started just talking with a bed sheet
and then i had a podcast in fox news
um and you can see a lot of rise and
fall sort of conservative new media
stars yeah and what i would say is the
fall with most of those people is that
they didn't love it it wasn't always
sincere and i'm not going to name any
names rush limbaugh was he flaunts her
people who point to oh
multiple marriages okay there's mr
family values divorces listen doesn't
mean that he doesn't believe in marriage
mr family values got addicted to uh
painkillers well that's one of the
biggest problems united states right now
but no one could ever say that rush
limbaugh was insincere
and didn't believe what he espoused and
that's why this show is i think i think
that's a big reason because i'm not that
talented
that this show has consistently grown is
listen you can smell it on me you can go
back and look
when not only was i not making money i
was guaranteed to lose money and same
thing with rush limbo on am radio
exactly there was no money in am radio
and he said i don't care i get to do
what i want my own thing
so i really do admire him and i i just
want everyone to i don't know if there
are great biographies out there but to
really appreciate that the impact that
he had
on on media and on the political
landscape
and there's really nobody out there who
can fill his shoes and the best that we
can do
is um try and help fill that void so
that you don't feel
alone uh but right now we also oh you
know what here before we go
this is something i remember i was there
this year at cpac this might have been
the year
that andrew breitbart had that
conversation with me um
rush limbaugh i want you to hear this is
what i think perfectly crystallizes what
he was all about
let me tell you who we conservatives are
we love people when we look out
over the united states of america when
we are anywhere when we see
a group of people such as this or
anywhere
we see americans we see human beings
we don't see groups we don't see victims
we don't see people we want to exploit
what we see
what we see is potential yeah i remember
he gave a speech similar to that when i
was
at a place in los angeles at the reagan
ranch and i didn't know that he was
mostly deaf and i thought like what a
dick because i said hi and he
kind of looked at me he's looking to
read my lips and afterwards someone came
over and said like oh hey yeah
let you know like he actually has seen
some of your stuff and likes it and i
never had any personal interactions with
him but he was
and he's very shy by the way he's very
very gentle very meek in person
um i token always just asking if he
could go pee no you gotta
now you lay in it but i'm surprised as
to how much pinker you are than than
than him we might need to adjust the
lighting and have you guys switch switch
seats
let's let's have you switch seats and
then we'll go back
and one more thing about russia okay all
right really quickly
i i have him to thank for largely for my
wife's political
viewpoints right because her mom
listened to wrestling ball 24
7. yeah so much so that my dad's the
same way yeah when he's always in the
garage
his dad's really black yeah he is a
rarity um
when she was buying a new car her mom uh
she actually went over to the salesman
and like pulled on his leg as like a
really young kid and said sir does this
car come with rush limbaugh
[Laughter]
because she knew her bob wanted to
listen to rush limbaugh all the time on
the radio and so
one of our first days man who turned
around was yeah it was russia
selling cars yeah i am right but one of
our first dates uh not first days
probably you know three or four or five
and i can't remember we went and saw
jordan peterson and i was like
this is perfect like this girl has all
of the same values that i have which is
much more important
than some of the things people think are
important for people and she demanded
you take her to a lobster dinner she did
and tossed something in the tank uh
let's check back in actually right now
thomas finnegan as we
and by the way i really want to hear
your comments how you found out about
rush limbaugh and how it's affected you
him passing i
i know this isn't usually what we do
here on the show we have some
information to get to on
the town hall and the uh the gun bill
but i do want to hear because even for
me
i'm not gonna lie i'm sad i'm gonna miss
the guy uh but we're still here to help
you
we are not abandoning our post and we
are fortunate to have power so thomas
finnegan on the ground is going to uh
continue showing you
how to stay safe thomas finnegan let's
go
okay thomas finnegan are you there
sir hi stephen uh another factor to keep
in mind during these frigid temperatures
is dehydration is still a factor
when it's cold out and there's snow on
the ground yep and an important
resource at your disposal is your own
urine oh no
which is actually stereotype coming to
keep you from dehydrating
nope that's actually not true at all
thomas don't do that don't do that you
don't have so dark
thomas everyone hold on let me talk in
here don't do that don't do that thomas
we don't need you to do that why is he
doing why is he doing what happened
why is he why is he not stopping his
earpiece is frozen
oh no how does earpiece get frozen
oh my god
people at home don't do this
that's that's not oh my gosh
thomas that's not what we do on the show
that's not
you should also keep moving yeah keep
moving and stay warm that's probably
gonna help we'll do some aerobics you
could
do a snow angel
oh no
rush would be proud you tried to stop
him
you really did uh let's go here to the
biden town hall i know what happened we
did the extended interview with alex
jones by the way it's like another hour
and a half if you guys are mug club
members uh
at the blaze uh because some of it
definitely could not be on youtube
there's some bombshells in there but
there was here's the thing with biden
and the gaffes with the town hall
uh biden you know people make gaffes
where they just say something out of
turn maybe it doesn't maybe they
misspelled potato
biden is remarkable and that he makes
gaffes where he misspeaks
but it's also sort of intertwine it
becomes this amalgamate of
misspeaking and being a compulsive liar
so it's also somehow accurately untrue
well he can't get something correct by
accident so let's go through a few of
them these are just this is just a
highlight reel of the worst
mistakes he made gaffes and then we'll
get to some specifics which were flat
out dishonest
everybody knows i like kids better than
people
the central principle of xi jinping
is that there must be a united tightly
controlled
china and he uses his rationale for the
things he does based on that
forceful i i said and by the he said he
he gets it wait
what can you just was that the word of
the day no no i don't think that was the
word of the day no no keep playing the
clip
culturally there are different norms at
each country
and they their leaders are expected to
follow i get up in the morning and look
at jill and say where the hell are we
i think the other was uh he said
something what did he say what did
do you have that he said no no i think
he did say it let me see go back go back
go play it again
go back let me see everybody knows i
like kids better okay i don't use
his rationale for the things he does
based on that forceful
i i said and by the he said he but he
said oh that is
[Applause]
comment below it helps us with the
algorithm on youtube whoever most
creatively uses but he say
in uh a sentence you get uh in this case
you're going to get a skin graft from
token and spell it correctly which can
also be used to stain glass windows oh
that's good
i can't laugh anymore it's a kegel
exercise really can i go pee
okay fine you can go guys poor guy hurry
up
this is a horrible program uh here's
something else that biden did that was
remarkable to me
biden said that uh
he didn't have any vaccine at all when
he came into office
when he came in we didn't have any
vaccine um so here you go like i thought
did he
no he actually said this remember when
you and i you i shouldn't say it that
way as you remember but
when you and i talked last we talked
about it's one thing that the vaccine
which we didn't have when we came into
office
okay okay so first off here's the thing
everyone knows that's in that's a lie
that's a lie yeah that is a lie there's
inaccuracies there's untrue
there's that is a lot but you say
is but
he said okay uh but
here's the one thing it would be one
thing to lie where you're disconnected
from yeah like you lie about what's
going on
you know in uganda or something right
because no one's gonna be able to affect
them but joe biden
feels such a lack of accountability the
media will call him on anything
that he lied about not having a vaccine
when he is on
camera getting said vaccine two months
before he entered office he got this
vaccine in december here's the clip
we've got a live shot there uh
president-elect joe biden
he can't remember december 19 vaccine
but we are a year ago
yeah but uh that's an important part
every living president should have a
shot
at the same time on that television set
and when that clip ends he grabbed her
ass
oh gosh sexist so
it's just it it is here's something else
too that he claimed he also said
we're you know in our goal too we
weren't able we didn't have the vaccine
at all but we're going to try and have
a hundred million vaccines in a hundred
days
which if you if you do the math i think
is if you do the 100 million
vaccines
[Music]
it's a million vaccines a day right yeah
that's exactly what donald trump did
oh but he's taking credit when biden got
that shot they were at the rate of a
million vaccines a day
but we're gonna do 100 million over 100
days oh that's fantastic
what did you say what a shitty person
yeah exactly we'll set our goal at what
you've already achieved by the way
here's liberals here's your argument he
didn't lie okay fine
he didn't lie he is so out of it that he
doesn't remember getting a vaccine two
months ago that's your other argument
which would you prefer yeah he lied
or he's out of his mind i can't remember
how do you not remember getting a
vaccine yeah two months ago
pick yeah pick it he's either crazy he
has dementia
or he is lying you know what listen i'll
be gracious here
i think it's a little both um
let's not forget joe biden who's said
racist thing
after and i hear let me be clear i don't
think joe biden is a racist no no no no
no
i do not think joe biden is a racist i
think he's an idiot
that's different that is different he
said yeah barack obama you know he's the
first
clean articulate black man first off
he's not the first clean articulate
black man
yeah there have been many so that's
factually inaccurate also maybe he
doesn't remember
most black people and he said
it's like you can't go into a 7-eleven
without a slight indian accent which
probably
doesn't even make sense if you're saying
you have to have an indian accent you're
just imitating the cashier
and being racist that's rude he meant to
say you can't go into a seven level
without seeing someone with an indian
accent which by the way you want to
bring in
uh with open borders and maps cheap
labor
so he's made so many races it's very
very hard to keep track
but he did another one at this town hall
which i thought was
particularly if i were black and
sometimes i
pretend to be yeah would be particularly
unnerving he said this
about the minorities the uh the other
part portion is a lot of people don't
know how to register
not everybody in the community in the
hispanic and the african-american
community particularly in
rural areas that are distant and or
inner city
districts know how to use know how to
get online
to determine how to get in line for that
covert vaccination at the at the
walgreens
here's the thing he was so busy he was
so busy fixating on the catchphrase you
know he's like i'm gonna say they don't
know how to get online
to get in line yeah what are you going
to say before that colored folks and uh
and browns
let's maybe smooth over the setup said
that minorities didn't know how to get
hey hold on a second we happen to have
some minorities here in studio smooth
manny's in colombia can you
right now can you see just uh actually
register for covet vaccine online
there we go let's go you know what toca
now and you can do it as well at the
same time oh
i'm done you're done nope yep found it
got it wow nice
well there you go that's that's just
proves it disproves it
completely he expects that none of you
will be able to do it he's drunk
that's a drunken asian who found it
really quickly that's
that's the worst kind of minority
to require fine motor skills that's
going to oh my gosh
you just said an entire group of people
don't know how to get online yeah yeah
that's basically multiple integral
blacks and latinos
well exactly but it's this is the
one many in a line of these kinds of
things well they don't know how to get
id's either because it's racist to make
somebody have an idea to vote because
they can't figure it out you know for
the life of them
it's like how can you possibly get away
with saying things like this if you want
to say it's hard for low-income families
to get online because they may not have
a computer or internet access
fine that's different but don't throw
this in i disagree
i don't understand it i don't even think
that's fine there are very very few
there are very few poor people in the
inner city i agree we do not have a
smartphone i know who do not have any
kind of a computer or who can't go to
their property it's at least some it's
it's
an argument you can try and make and not
sound racist doing so
right and so in him he just is like this
will sound racist so let's go that way
in biden's case that is an argument that
he could try and make and try
to sound racist doing so oh he might be
it's almost an attempt
he's like an olympic shot put of racism
he's like all right use the wrong
term
[Laughter]
gold uh wasn't he also a racial jungle
like he didn't want to yeah he didn't
want to
grow up in a racial jungle listen i
don't think he's a racist i think he's
an
i think he's an old idiot right and i
think he's okay with stereotypes which
is kind of racist but it doesn't mean he
hates black people yeah but put this put
these words in the mouth of somebody
else that the media hates on the right
and they're racist i said listen folks
black people don't know how to get
online
they don't have the opportunity to use
the internet because they they
listen we can't expect them to be able
to get online like white people they're
not the same as white people we need to
offer programs to federally subsidize
the blacks and latinos because they are
fundamentally less capable
of using the internet there i said it
that would be everywhere oh it would
absolutely he would be canceled off of
everything but mr mr
uh bosley himself basically he's a
haircut
no i got it were you looking to say
something there uh troy junior
no i'm good were you looking to go to
the bathroom is that what it was i'm
upset
okay you guys just had a little
you guys just had a little bit to drink
you didn't you didn't take shrooms
you wouldn't know all right before we
move on to the next story the gun
control and the crime wave this is
really important because
it's really pervasive they're trying to
trick you into a the biggest gun grab
since the assault weapons ban they're
using skyrocketing crime by the way
it has nothing to do with guns but
before that this is also important
uh this z is the only way this
yeah person uh tick tock uh this is
spreading around
um now it's a problem to talk about
obesity
and capitalism anyway this is what will
be coming to schools near you
the obesity epidemic isn't real and it
shouldn't be an anti-capitalist talking
point
when someone unironically references the
obesity epidemic or even uses the word
obesity
it tells me they really don't know what
they're talking about when it comes to
fatness this use of the word obesity
stems directly from the bmi
which was created by a eugenicism
only on blood bodies and cow fatness is
not an epidemic
fat people existed before capitalism and
before colonization
fat phobia is a direct result of
anti-blackness and it has
consequences for many groups of
indigenous folks and other people of
color
as well as fat folks when you make the
obesity epidemic a real symptom of
capitalism
you are not only ostracizing fat people
from anti-capitalist thinking
but also actively ignoring that the
health outcomes related to obesity
are more accurately attributed to food
deserts and
fat phobic discrimination in health care
the obesity epidemic was created by
western medicine to avoid addressing the
actual causes of health inequity which
is what we as anti-capitalists
should be doing there's so much there
she just said food desert does that mean
that she's uh black or latino she can't
get online and order amazon fresh
there's no such thing as a food desert
anymore okay sorry and i don't
let's just go through and we're going to
circle back on this next week but let's
just go through these soft
racism of low expectations yeah that you
see from the left today okay we go up to
rush limbaugh where they canceled them
he was just saying hey look this
quarterback doesn't really have great
stats and i think this stems from the
fact that people want to have a diverse
versity quota for someone as a
quarterback he's not very good they are
desiring to have a black quarterback
who's not as capable boom
that guy's canceled now you have joe
biden saying black people cannot get
online because they're not
intelligent enough they're not capable
enough they don't have the resources
basically saying all black people are
poor living in ghettos and they don't
have
the wherewithal to find internet access
and now here saying that
uh what is it the fat phobia is a direct
result of anti-blackness
you are saying that all black people are
fat and it's outside of their control
and this this person is trying
to ensure that she can he she can do
whatever
g z wants because i don't want to get
back i don't know if that's a male to
female or
i honestly don't know i don't know maybe
it's someone from the chas bono
look-alike foundation that's as close as
i can get
as saying i shouldn't have to pay for my
health care and by the way
obesity is not a problem and one other
thing and then i know token one's gonna
have a drunken slur but
one other thing here that really really
bothers me is with the trans thing and i
don't know why this doesn't bother more
people
is it just creates a stereotype of women
and men
what is it like that's a beautiful brave
trans male to female what is it
makeup giant fake tits they look like a
barbie things that they would say are
negative stereotypes
negative standards that are being put on
to put on to women right
and then what do they think it is to be
a man just be a fat guy that's what they
think they think i think
i get fat i have a double chin i'm a man
no men are far more than that and women
are far more than that you have reduced
them to a stereotype so that you can say
you were born in the wrong body
i was reading an article about fallon
fox and this 50 year old who's playing
college basketball
with girls and they both said like and
no one ever they're like and when i came
out to let them know that i was trans
they were shocked okay
no they weren't no it's like when you
give someone socks to the christmas
gifts like they loved it oh
socks what you're you were a man
i couldn't tell by your size xxl gloves
and
46 inch chest and 32 waist
i couldn't tell by your calves that
looked like sasquatch from one of the a
and e
shows what yeah you're three feet taller
than the rest of the girls they lose a
single
game that coach needs to be fired i
don't understand how you lose here's the
thing right you can't say women are
weaker than men you're not supposed to
say women are weaker than they're less
athletic right that therefore women's
sports are less interesting you can't
say that but if you read these articles
from falun fox and from this 50 year old
playing college
basketball with girls they say no one
knew because uh uh
of my strength and my endurance they
weren't any better than them so right
there
okay with the stereotypes you're saying
see they couldn't tell
because i'm weak skinny fat unless i
have less fast twitch muscle fibers
like the inferior woman it's unreal
that it's only acceptable when somehow
you go to trans
all stereotypes are okay so we can teach
you the big lie
oh that's fantastic it's fatness stephen
yeah that's like that's a protected
group now
she didn't it wasn't one other body she
was put into his three other bodies
apparently epidemic
it's not healthy and it's not beautiful
you're about to say something token
yeah no i mean that was mainly about
fatness but my problem with that clip
wasn't the fatness like
thank god for capitalism because
capitalism gave us the gillette safety
razor
that pencil mustache was just like it's
like look at it i wasn't even listening
to what she was saying
this is a thing too they just said she
like chase bono she's
i'll be a man i'll get really really fat
and they're putting miracle grow on
their face like
look i'm just like right i'm just like
you no no no
just like if a man says that he's a
woman in his late 30s and starts beating
up a woman he doesn't know what it's
she doesn't they say she's a woman women
we don't know i don't know what it's
like as a man to get your first
menstrual cycle
i don't know what it's like to have to
understand what it's like to carry a
child
i don't know what it's like to go
through these hormonal changes and by
the way
just because you say you're a man now
you don't know what it's like to have to
hide your perpetual boner with a binder
between classes
every time the bell rings in high school
because your brain starts wandering
or you have a teacher who albeit was
chubby but you could not
ride what she had to offer in my moral
and religious education this was really
uncomfortable she walked over and
correct my paper french canadian she's
like
and uh okay what did you get for me i'm
like nothing just go away
just go away give me enough just get out
of here let's
stop acting like we fully experience
each other's plight because we took
estrogen our testosterone or put on a
moo moo
okay we're going to circle back to that
next week do we have to
uh we have to okay let's get to the
common sense gun uh gun reform common
sense common sense gun reform so this is
uh after the three year anniversary of
the parkland shooting we do have to get
going soon and we're gonna have uh
dr choi what's up doc where we're going
to explain to you rose
asian rosacea guys keep drinking um
three year anniversary for parkland
biden called for a congress uh to enact
common sense gun law
and um keep in mind before we move on
with this that this is the guy
the guy who thinks that blacks and brown
people can't get online
uh and uh this is the guy who wants to
take your guns away
[Music]
guess what you're not allowed anywhere
don't try me pal yeah
i said are you able to go that's right
i would love to see joe biden former
vice president joe biden do it change my
mind
oh man we need a bet push up there's so
many words in the guns we need to ban
machine guns like well okay well you
know and then i'm fine with my arrow 15.
that yeah it's not a machine gun do you
think you need 100 rounds
what i think i left the iron on do you
want to do
the push-ups how do you do it right now
fat yeah
let me go find a guy in a wheelchair i
can make fun of him and a black guy so i
can mock him with my sprint service that
he never knows how to use
you ain't black
and ar 14 is not a thing and it's not a
machine
it's brand new he's an idiot uh and this
is the guy who wants to now control your
firearm so this is the they're
predicating it and by the way
you can see the full bill we re we did
it last week i believe we did
in depth what the actual bill is this is
more about the crime wave because
they're using this as the springboard
for the bill it's not true okay it's not
true that there's an epidemic of gun
violence so let me go through this
really quickly uh he referenced this
last year there's been a rise in violent
crime okay
this says uh and in this season of so
much loss last year's historic increase
in homicides across america including
the gun violence disproportionately
devastating black and brown individuals
in our cities has that were okay that's
absolutely true
now crime was consistently going down
particularly violent crime
under donald trump and it was going down
mostly under obama outside of the 2016
uh riots the black lives matter riots
without common sense gun laws okay so
crime was going down
down down down and then all of a sudden
it spiked
okay it spiked so no change in the gun
laws what do you think actually led to
an increase in national crime
[Applause]
this is a mostly a protest uh it is not
uh it is not generally speaking unruly
okay good then what's happening here
that looks like it was done by a guy
named bubba in west virginia with an art
[Applause]
but for the most part they have been
very very peaceful
there's a car on fire behind him
yes yes so peaceful this is the one
thing that people don't understand they
they say well actually crime is going up
because of covet and people aren't
saying
no okay there's some truth to that but
the truth is you're not having an
epidemic
of first time uh homicide
right people people who are committing
homicide you're not having a first-time
violent felons you're not having an
epidemic of first-time arsonists what
you are having
is violent criminals serial violent
criminals who are
acting in a way that is completely
unfettered because of a decreased police
presence
and because they feel emboldened by this
administration including kamala harris
who said they won't let up they
shouldn't let up they should continue
i think that bra needs to be impeached
uh and not in the way she thinks a weird
sex term she needs to be in peace
from office let me give you this really
quickly so police reform
and specific laws that have been enacted
not too much in the rhetoric from the
left is what led to the increase in
violent crime
after de blasio he cut 484 million from
the nypd budget
they had a 130 percent increase in
shootings
here's another policy that was really
big uh new york
they eliminated cash bail so basically
becomes a revolving door of criminals
after they eliminated cash bail two
months after
in new york city 482 people were
released
and they committed 846 new
crimes directly increased gun violence
in new york city because cash bill a lot
of these people were gun criminals
here's something that you have from the
new york post a bastion of conservatism
to be sure 3793 people were arrested on
gun charges last year from january 1st
november 40th
only 450 remained in jail out of almost
000 450 remain in jail everyone else was
out of the released
450 247 were accused of a new crime
within 60
days now of those people
only 32 of those repeat offenders
are in jail people who committed violent
crimes
with firearms or knives or arsonary
against their fellow citizen because
racism what is it about black lives
matter that every time a peaceful
protest breaks out with them violent
crime goes up they're criminals i mean
look at the spikes we have we had it
going down blm happens in 2016 boom
violent crime goes back up right
it starts going back down and all of a
sudden they need to peacefully protest
and make sure they get their nikes
and all of a sudden it goes back up
again yeah and i don't you know the
truth is new york is
because new york actually was
single-handedly responsible for a huge
decrease in climate
crime under clinton because of rudy
giuliani yeah it's there are a few big
cities now
really you can name them on both hands
that are responsible for the increased
gun crime across the country there are
there is no increased crime in the
suburbs there's no increased crime in
rural areas
it happens in liberally controlled
democratic strongholds
like new york where before this and
they've had the strictest gun laws in
the country you can't conceal carry in
new york without a sheriff signing off
on it and he really doesn't like you
that's not going to happen can you find
a shirt bill new york city it's hard
they don't have sheriffs but here's a
here's another thing by the way this is
something that you can track
look at we have a chart here of violent
crime surges
to the letter it coincides with riots 68
2016 2020. hmm all right after the 2015
riots
with freddie gray baltimore police they
became much less aggressive in policing
field interviews where police were
approaching a suspect they dropped by 70
and uh suspected narcotic offenses
dropped 30 percent because everyone
everyone got clean
freddie gray inspired everyone to say i
gotta put down this crack pipe
and then hunter crack pipes free crack
everybody yeah it's all for me
like when i used to go to weddings and i
used to just take them and i used to
take the appetizers when i had no money
everybody loves crab cakes baltimore by
the way they broke their homicide record
with 343. oh good for you baltimore
yeah so that's not a good thing so
common sense gun laws like new york
stripping citizens of their right to
protect themselves and then and this is
the thing we don't want you protecting
yourself
call the cops well there are no cops
yeah you made sure
you took away our guns said call the
cops you took away your cops
just go out and fire that shotgun up in
the air and that'll scare them off
there's a couple
it'll be illegal at the same time
yeah so you basically in the police
force you just you just hit on this it's
not only did you tell every police
officer out there that we're not going
to give you enough money for the
training that we think you need so that
you won't go to the gun first which is
what they've been saying for years
they need more training so they won't do
that we're also now going to make
police officers public enemy number one
and on everybody's hit list
yeah it's shocking to me that you have
to pay people to come be police you know
i have people
you know i have people in the black
community right now who are who think
cops are killers and
it's no snitching culture because
democrats have told them that black
police officers are going out there and
lynching black people
do you know why you have vaccine
hesitancy in the minority communities
who you are so
unbelievably out of touch with joe biden
because you kamala harris and cuomo said
you wouldn't use the vaccine if it was
developed under donald trump and now you
go why aren't they taking the vaccines
it must be racism no
it's you and your soft expectations of
people who are who make up your voting
constituency and the fact that you're
not really interested in helping them
okay but speaking of helping people you
have to check in one more time to make
sure that we keep you all safe
uh thomas finnegan on the ground
okay thomas finnegan are you there sir
don't worry he bounces back quickly yeah
he's tough he liked a little bouncing
disney ball with the sing-along
uh we have to get going we have we're
gonna have a what's up doc segment with
choi junior's father uh and he'll
explain to us asian rosacea
everyone on youtube thank you so much if
you're a club member go and watch there
of course comment as soon as this is up
that's what helps us just like and
comment if you want the show to continue
we are every day 10 a.m eastern monday
through thursday
youtube i don't want to say you know i
would say thank you but instead you can
uh do it just piss off